We have a voicemail number. That
number is two one nine two. David
P. Got a very interesting voicemail about
the Supreme Court and the upcoming election.
Hi, David. This is John Higson, member
in Good Standing from Highbridge,
by the way, I love member in good standing.
You could be a member in bad standing. I
like that. We have a clarification
here. A member in good standing.
Here's what I predict happens on election night.
Since Trump has, you know, inspired all of his
voters to vote on Election Day.
Right. Walk in on election night. He wins
in the walk. In voting count. Yes.
Then the next day,
he has the Supreme Court suspend the count
of all the mail in ballots because it will
be injurious to his reelection campaign and
they will cite Bush v. Gore as precedent.
That's interesting. The idea of citing Bush
v. Gore as president for hijinx at the court.
I've not actually heard that specifically
before, but certainly this is the general fear
that the Supreme Court now
with the six to three majority,
thanks to last night's swearing in of Amy CONI
Barrett, will be used to stop the counting
of mail in ballots, particularly in key states.
Pennsylvania is the one that comes to mind
because they don't even start counting mail in
ballots until the polls close on Election Day up
that. This is exactly the nightmare scenario
we've been talking about for sure. And is Joe
Biden ready with lawyers to prevent it? I don't
know. Eric Garcetti told me he is. I don't know.
We will talk today on the bonus show about the
idea of expanding the court and what is implicit
there of water on the moon. NASA's Sofia Craft has
discovered water on the moon, and Kazakhstan now
likes the latest Borat movie.
Very, very interesting stuff on
today's Bonas show. Get instant access by
becoming a member at join Pacman dot com.